[Musique]
y'avait plus con franchement c'est
cependant un peu d'imagination et à
l'étude de rapidité
voilà vraiment cette le buzzer et un
petit trophée là tu peux rentrer chez
toi si tu gagnes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue sur le quiz numéro
2 on est de retour pour tester les
connaissances en culture de youtube mais
candidats qui sont autour de la table
à ma gauche enjoy phoenix à lui nous
avons juste à côté serait la team
trasher cecab direct comme ça à ma
droite les avants la team espadon jardin
dr ousmane sy plein gaming avec son
année à son animal
on va commencer avec la première manche
face à des qcm trouver votre pouce ont
commencé avec les espadons quelle chaîne
youtube n'existe pas simplement deborah
juste zoé vraiment que sophie uniquement
leïla ouais ouais comme ça de visu
vraiment que sophie sam ça me choque un
peu enfin ça veut dire qu'il ya une
chaîne qui s'appelle des valeurs seul
manceau futur uniquement les lames
intriguée elle est là sur ce coup là je
crois que vous êtes laissé à jouer mais
je pense qu uniquement là et là c'est
moi je préfère je crois que tu es
d'accord comme ça ça m'intéresse
fonctionne à dire uniquement les la
tenait pas du tout deux points c'était
vraiment que sophie c'est tellement
dommage donc mon raisonnement est a été
très bien du coup en train de douter de
conclure les trashers huppert laquelle
de ces vidéos n'est pas une vidéo de
mahounou il met du caca sur sa copine ça
c'est fini mais du caca dans la bouche
de sa copine il fait caca sur des gens
il met du caca dans ses yeux
mon dieu il en a fait 3 m à 3 qui existe
mauno du cookie un vieux tube heures qui
réagit à des vidéos mon cerveau est vide
comme les gens qui cliquent sur ces
vidéos
trash heures 30 le cac a dans la bouche
de la copine c'est quand même hein c'est
dans la bouche tout ce qui est très peu
ta clique c'est ce qui va sûrement la
france à ses 400 mille bulles kaka dans
la boue minimum moi je dirais il fait
caca sur des gens parce que c'est quand
même compliqué je vais avec nick on peut
on peut fermer plus tactiquement
techniquement il faut le faire il faut
faire franchement je n'y crois pas moi
je dirais plutôt une mais ducati alors
là vous je savais pas fiable cela je ne
suis pas je suis pas sûr qu pose sur
quoi te qu'on fait mais en fait c'est
surtout si on vit dans un monde bien ce
serait dans la bouche et sa copine je
suis prête et donc mais précieux il n'ya
pas seulement
en fait c'est existe des zones et
essayer mais du caca dans ses yeux
ça m'a pas dans les yeux on s'en fout ça
nul vraiment très très dur à ceux qui
sans doute avec scott acquis grand
gagnant cellule l'a pour l'instant
laissée s'étaient tues mais spa dont
l'oscar en fait partie quel titre de
vidéos de the khairi 78 n'existe pas en
la chance méfiez vous des gens méfier et
dégustation complètement iphone regardez
er ce que son om temarii fait à yes j'en
ai marre
n apostrophe le st alors là c'est
compliqué
j'aime trop regarder cette personne moi
si activement et les quatre pourraient
exister car tout est bien je te
conseillerais de plus m'écouter
parce que je donne nouvelle réponse donc
année c'est à dire une réponse mais ils
sont beaucoup de vidéos dans la peine et
l'innovation leri pas mal de ses vidéos
par jour
donc je vais partir aussi sûr déguster
des glaces complètement fin c'est le
premier point pour la peau ce caillou
les trashers
salut je m'habille surtout pas avec
quelle tuto draguer n'existe pas sur
youtube draguer oui j'avais à draguer
une caissière séduire une fille qui dort
séduire une fille qui n'est pas
intéressé séduire une fille qui courent
à moi je dirais césure une fille qui
tord ça sent le piège le petit piège
sipri ans à moi j'irai vers celle là
aussi madrague et une caissière je pense
que c'est totalement un tuto faisable
c'est du risque qu'ils courent pareil
donc il n'est pas intéressé je pense que
c'est typiquement le genre de chose que
tu tapes quand tu as deux copines donc
je dirais cette jeune fille qui dormait
la première et la dernière fois j'étais
composer quelque chose n'a pas marché
donc c'est pas parce qu'une fille qui
dors tu va se battre on se dit c'est pas
possible
et c'est pour ça qu'on va cliquer c'est
pas possible c'est elle dort quand même
oh là là c'est incroyable
réponse une fille qui dorment on va voir
c'est aussi le premier point
j'aime bien c'est bien de films courts
parce que ça évoque vraiment la fuite
mais vas-y saiper web c'est une belle
égalité je trouve pour cette première
manche
il va falloir maintenant partir sur un
petit peu de rapidité faut se mettre un
peu dans le contexte vous imaginez
éducation nationale ne va pas bien plus
personne ne s'intéresse aux cours
d'histoire
ils ont décidé de s'inspirer de ce qui
se fait sur youtube donc je vous donne
un titre put a cliqué il faut imaginer
l'événement historique qui en découle un
militaire what the fuck s'était pas
l'inde
j'espère que l'on est on bien joué tori
times deux points ma mère est vierge
la vierge la naissance de jésus
on tente le record du plus gros iceberg
et challenge ça tourne mal dernier pour
attention sur cette manche pire
traversée en mer de ma vie et qu'elle
accueille en arrivant louis non hollande
le vendée globe ont pas du tout yannick
avait un bateau dans l'histoire naples
en croit la presse qu'il tiendra salle
peut-être s'y connaît en bateau dans
l'histoire de débarquement et octobre
[Applaudissements]
une petite manche d'histoire comme ça
histoire de se mettre de se mettre en
bouche
attention on va revenir sur une manche
qui a cartonné d'art fois c'est lequel
youtuber faut deviner de quel youtuber
je parle ça parle essentiellement de
youtuber francophone qu'elle du tube
heures a dit à propos de moi
podcast romande est nul mais de là à
voir 4 millions de vues mouais le salon
gagne parce que lui-même fait des
papiers squeeze bien entendu j'ai
entendu un peu notre est un petit géant
quotidiennement
attention c'est en partie qu'elle
youtuber a sorti un spectacle en dvd oui
bien évidemment
quel tube heures a fait une vidéo en
irak legrand jd oui il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de points je sautais
l'attention qu'elle youtuber va sortir
un album incroyable qu'est youtube
heures a été champion de baby foot c'est
warteck oui elle les a toutes un dernier
attention quel tube heures à arrêter
puis les revenus puis l'a arrêté puis
revendue à arrêter ce qui nous coureurs
n'ont pas mal qu'à youtube heures a fait
une vidéo le vrai retour est là pour le
prouver
the bricks 9 oui
c'est un peu notre part on a tous fait
partie des premiers gros youtuber les
trashers faut se réveiller un petit peu
c'est un problème dont nous allons
arriver sur la manche plus tard clic je
vais vous montrer des miniatures et à
faire deviner le titre cette fois ci
c'est trois points qui vont être gagné
on va commencer avec les perdants s'il
vous plaît vous voyez cette miniature
quel est le bon titre rentrer dans le
mauvais trou je renverse mas cup
en fait ce n'était pas un verre a shot 2
j'ai mes règles partirai sur le jeu
renversé mcup tuer les petites gouttes
de sang comme ça ça me fait penser que
les gens aiment les règles sur la nature
des règles dans le titre tu la
connaissent pas non je ne connais pas je
converse mas cup c'est soft je fais
confiance aux jeux renversés à kiev je
sais mon dernier mot jean piat et
c'était rentrer dans le mauvais trou ne
sommes pas là pour juger avec la cup et
tout regardez bien cette miniature un
punk je lui fait croire que je couche
avec sa copine ça tourne mal
brenke la maîtresse crois que j'ai mangé
décret
franck j'appelle le proviseur à 22h ils
craignent que j'avais fait croire aux
cpe que j'ai fugué alors je le dis
désiré dit être donc donc c'est la
première ici ça se voit qu'il a fait
c'est trois points c'était bien je lui
fait croire que je couche avec sa copine
ça tourne mal
si on fait je pense deux fois trois
points c'est peut-être suffisant en fait
je m'en faut dire que l'on attend dé
vous a perdu alors mal et pour le fun
découvrez cette miniature nous avons
comme titre mon chauffeur hubert est
magnifique
mon chauffeur hubert ma kidnappé bon je
suis fort hubert m'a giflée mon
chauffeur hubert m'a reconnu c'est la
deuxième bon chauffeur maïté ou sur le
toit
oui elle s'appelle tana mon jeu et je
crois que c'est ça mais j'espère que
c'est ce à quoi ont défilé le times
comme ses habitants
et c'est 3 points si on s'en réfère du
coup au titre avec tu vois ça fait
kidnapper par un chauffeur hubert c'est
une frustration j'ai envie d'aller voir
toutes ces vidéos
qu'est ce qui se passe vraiment en train
de donner des centaines
ça part de derrière miniature à vous de
deviner il vole ma mini moto je ne la
chaîne youtube de vos dégustations
candice anne qui tourne mal avec momo je
surprends momoa la chicha à quoi qu'il
arrive ça tourne extrêmement mal
globalement ça tourne mal a vraiment
souffert moumour je la connais bien mr
est oui cette saison où il a vraiment
plus cher
franchement être anglais son petit frère
pour une dégustation de bonbons c'est
quand même ça me paraît un peu à vous
écouter on finalise son frère césar
annonce je surprends moment où la chine
a fait don il nous ramènerait chez lui
pour défendre et à bah oui mais le des
fonds se bat pour faire des vues un
moment tu es obligé de faire un petit
détour à les bons coups pour la chicha
sans fondement la chicha et bah c'était
la chaîne youtube de momo quoi lui fait
du mal j'ai l'impression c'est une
victoire écrasante des espadons qu'on
peut applaudir à prouver qu'ils n'ont
pas vu des mecs traces de caries je suis
très déçu c'était mon expertise tant pis
et je le remercie beaucoup d'être venu
d'avoir tenter la chance même si moi je
devrais arriver jusqu'en finale
voici donc et deux pour moi qui aie vit
encore une fois extrêmement stressant
vous pouvez faire un petit à petit
chiffres émis de commencer si si tu as
vraiment je suis prêt gerland sur quelle
chaîne pouvons nous retrouver qualité
multi oui vrai ou faux dali lafarge a
fait une vidéo des mutations prick faut
que tout le monde c'est cosy de fine
brothers ont déposé un projet de vidéo
lequel react oui avant d'être blogueur
qui a été la principale activité duarte
gamer oui sur quelle chaîne pouvons nous
retrouver entre autres lola du mini et
elliot cover garden oui vrai ou faux
matthew mcconaughey dispose de sa propre
chaîne youtube jeunes archilla pas mal o
rama oui comment se nomme la chaîne de
yann et cox et anthony padilha ce match
oui dit flo et oli on dit et pas tu l'as
réal était membre de la white ifam que
veulent dire les initiales m sienne je
passe comment s'appelle le youtube ou
russes je ne sais pas comment s'appelle
le principe de finir un jeu vite
possible un speedrun est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas dire que j'ai directement
perdu mais youtube ouvrir ses rues tube
m cnc multichannel network d'accord et
du coup effectivement matthew
mcconaughey ya bien une chaîne youtube
avec quelques vidéos wii fait du blog
dégueulasse en mode 33-10 effet ouais je
sais pas si ça marche je préfère te dire
là c'est très bien je sais bien oui bah
ça peut m'aider non d'accord parce que
tu es prêt pour un champ on va voir top
claudia slg ça des délits qu il existe
une fanfiction érotique entre squeeze et
moi bref au quai le premier youtuber
français être victime de soi king du
vice oui sur quelle chaîne pouvait-on
retrouver la ferme jérôme plus si tard
youtuber qui a vu sa photo affichée dans
le métro si prompts sauf une fois où
charles est qu'elle youtuber s'est fait
connaître en commentant toutes les
vidéos postées sur youtube
zachary une presse hydraulique à des
millions d'abonnés au fond comment on
appelle une youtube e spécialisée dans
les livres une boucle
non comment s'appelle le service payant
de youtube
réd pour quels jeux vidéo normal
exclusion fait une chanson assassin's
creed qui a fêté ses deux millions
d'abonnés en répétant 22000 euros pour
une association
quel est le nom du célèbre duo de
youtuber adeptes du ralentissement pas
ce site and baby sur youtube c'était pas
toi la lutte internationale
c'est vraiment très impressionnant
souhaité la wii elle a aussi j'avoue je
pensais pas avoir un tel un tel niveau
c'était délire de max qui a inondé de
commentaires
tous les jockeys
les slogans guys pour les vidéo au
ralenti en mai be2 comme une merde par
exemple oui et les youtube the species
et un livre c'est les boues que tu buzz
eh ben j'ai l'impression qu'on a notre
grand gagnant qu'on peut applaudir au
coeur losemann mettant à profit
non parce que là lâche le sud a tué le
grand gagnant de ce quiz d'assurance est
très bon vous êtes ou donnez moi je suis
très fier de jouer pour les
applaudissent la coopération des parts
d'audience
et moi je vous dis a connu sur internet
abonnez vous êtes que 10 millions est
très contents les gens se rendent pas
compte mais en fait c'est facile vont
vraiment très lourd comme c'est très
cool quelque chose de marrant tout ban
en nuance et saint vallier m
[Musique]